Okay.
I did a story last week that was shocking.
Uh, in terms of the reaction because of how
universally positive the reaction was from
95% of the audience.
I can say almost anything on the show and
30, 40, if not 50% of the audience will vehemently
disagree with me to the point that they send
me insults and troll me and say horrible antisemitic
things.
But last year I said, hey, you know what I'm
thinking about getting off of social media.
Uh, it's totally toxic.
I've got people with five followers filling
my Twitter feed with nonsense attacks.
I don't care about there's fake drama.
There's the antisemitism, there's a very high
noise to signal ratio and it's interrupting
my work day.
Also, it's in her interrupting my personal
life.
It's preventing me from doing deeper work.
It's basically become a nuisance and study
after study suggests it's not very healthy
either psychologically, and it was one of
those random, not super political in the partisan
sense clips that I often throw into the show.
It has about a hundred thousand views.
It has 96% likes, uh, and reaction to the
clip has exploded in an almost completely
positive way, which is so different than just
about everything we do on the show.
Clearly this struck a nerve and I receive
more emails.
People actually taking the time to email me
rather than just leave a comment online about
this story.
Uh, that, that, that, that I've seen happen
with any other story that I can remember.
Hundreds of emails and just the first couple
of days from people mostly saying, Hey David,
you're, you're right.
Left wingers saying there's very little to
gain from spending more than like the minimum
required time for your job on social media
right wingers even saying, yeah, there's very
little advantage to spending all that time
on social media.
And the most common suggestion that I received
was, you know, do whatever I want with social
media for my personal life up.
But there's no denying that for work purposes,
abandoning social media wouldn't be great
for the show since it's been such a help and
boost to the show.
So the suggestion was David, just like make
it a very clearly defined piece of your job.
Set a specific amount of time for checking
into social media and responding to people,
which is basically what I've been doing.
But I decided over the last week to become
very, very narrow in terms of the social media
stuff and I actually find that it's making
me more responsive to the things I should
be responding to because I'm not having any
kind of overload.
I'm checking in on my accounts in a really
limited way.
If I see trolling, if I see nonsense stuff
that's not of obvious value, I ignore it.
I mute the people.
That's that.
And one of the really big changes I made personally
is I didn't even remove the apps from my phone.
I just removed them from my home screen.
So when I go to my homescreen now, uh, I have
very little other than pocket, which is an
app I use to put articles that I find interesting
there.
And just removing it from my home screen,
you might say, well you open your phone because
you got a text message and then you decide
I'm going to look at Facebook.
It's just as easy to find it from your list
of Apps, even if it's not on the home screen.
But what removing it from the homescreen did
is now I have to say, Oh, do I actually want
to go and search out the Facebook app or the
Twitter APP or whatever.
And just that little moment of pause almost
always leads to me saying, no, I actually
don't.
And, uh, it has reduced my time on social
media by probably 90%, no intrusions into
what I'm doing.
And you know what, yeah, some people will
send me a message and I'm not getting back
to them for three days, like over the weekend.
My life is fine, everything's fine.
And as far as the work piece goes, I'm checking
every social network in the morning, once
I'm done preparing the day's show.
And then I'm checking it sometime between
three and five in the afternoon, sort of as
I'm, uh, working, uh, finished working on
the next day's show and that's it.
And it's working really well.
So, so far, so good.
I look forward to talking to cal Newport about
this next week on the show.
He's written some really good books about
digital minimalism and the distraction that
is sort of ingrained into us, um, by the social
social networks.
And I encourage you to do the same.
And if you have questions for cal Newport
about this, either about his book, digital
minimum, minimum minimalism, digital minimalism,
or his book deep work, send them in to me
by email.
Why not?
And I will talk to cal about them next week.